We now follow a program that
parallels our development
for the case of the
Bernoulli process.
We will study the time
until the first arrival,
a random variable
that we denote by T1.
We're interested in
finding the probability
distribution of this
random variable.
And later on, we
will continue and try
to study the time
until the kth arrival.
Now T1 is a continuous
random variable,
because the Poisson process
runs in continuous time.
And therefore, it has a PDF.
But instead of finding
the PDF directly,
we will first find the CDF
of this random variable.
So we fix a certain
time, T. And we're
asking for the probability
that the first arrival happens
during this interval.
Now this is 1 minus
the probability
that the first arrival
happens outside this interval.
So we can write this probability
as 1 minus the probability
that T1 is bigger than t.
But what is this event?
The first arrival occurring
after time, little t,
is the same as saying that there
were no arrivals in the time
interval from 0 to little t.
And this probability
of 0 arrivals
in a time interval
of length t is
something for which we
already have a formula.
Take this formula and
replace k by 0, tau by t.
When k is equal
to 0, this term is
something to the 0-th
power equal to 1.
Using our convention, that
0 factorial is equal to 1,
we're left just with e
to the minus lambda t.
And this is the answer
for the CDF of the time
until the first arrival.
We then take the derivative.
And we find that the PDF of the
time until the first arrival
has this form, which is the
PDF of an exponential random
variable.
Of course, this
calculation here is
only valid for t's
that are non-negative.
For negative t's, the PDF
of T1 is, of course, 0.
For the exponential
random variable,
we have seen that it has certain
memorylessness properties.
Namely, if I
condition on an event
that nothing has occurred
until a certain time,
t, and I am interested
in the time from now
until the first arrival
occurs, this remaining
until the first arrival is again
an exponential distribution.
That is, looking
ahead from this time,
I will still wait an
exponentially distributed
amount of time until I
see the first arrival.
Whatever happened in
the past and how long
I have been waiting
doesn't matter.
Starting from this
time, I will still
wait an exponentially
distributed amount of time.
This is essentially
an expression
of a fresh start property of
the Poisson process, which
is analogous to the fresh start
properties for the Bernoulli
process.
And we will be discussing
this fresh start
property a lot more.
Having figured out
the distribution
of the time of
the first arrival,
let us now study the time of the
k-th arrival, a random variable
that we denote by Y sub
k, similar to the case
of the Bernoulli process.
This random variable
is a continuous one,
because arrivals happen
in continuous time,
so it takes continuous values.
And therefore, it will
be described by a PDF.
And this is what
we want to find.
In order to find it, we will
make use of the Poisson PMF
that we have already derived
for the number of arrivals
during an interval
of a fixed length.
One approach to
finding the PDF of Yk
is the usual program,
similar again
to what we did for the case
of the first arrival time.
We can first find CDF, and then
differentiate to find the PDF.
So what is the CDF?
We want to calculate
the probability
that Yk is less than or equal
to some number, little y.
Now what is this event?
The k-th arrival
occurs by time y.
This means that by time y,
we've had at least k arrivals.
We've had k arrivals, or maybe
k plus 1, or maybe k plus 2.
We've had some number
of arrivals, n,
in an interval of length, y.
And this is an event that
happens with this probability.
But we need to take into account
all of the possible values of n
that are at least as large as k.
Now we have a formula for this
probability, the probability
of n arrivals in an
interval of given length.
This is the Poisson PMF with
appropriate changes of symbols.
So we can take this expression,
substitute it here, and then
differentiate to do some
algebra and find the answer.
Instead of carrying
out this algebra,
however, we will proceed in
a more intuitive way that
will get us there
perhaps faster.
And the derivation that
we would follow actually
parallels the one
that we went through
in the case of the
Bernoulli process.
The intuitive argument
that we will use
will rest on the
interpretation of a PDF
in terms of probabilities
of small intervals.
So the PDF evaluated at
some particular point,
y, times delta, is
approximately the probability
that our random variable
falls within a delta interval
from this number, little
y, that we're considering.
So here's time 0, here's time
y, and here's time y plus delta.
We want to find or
to say something
about the probability of falling
inside this small interval.
Now what does it mean
for the k-th arrival
to fall inside this interval?
This is an event that
can happen as follows.
The k-th arrival falls
in this interval,
and we've had k minus 1 arrivals
during the previous interval.
What is the probability
of this event?
A basic assumption about
the Poisson process
is the independence assumption.
Therefore, having k minus
1 arrivals in this interval
and having one arrival
in this interval
are independent events.
Therefore, the probability
of this scenario
is the product of
the probabilities
that we've had k minus 1
arrivals in an interval
of length, y, times
the probability
that we've had one arrival in
an interval of length delta.
And that latter probability
is approximately
equal to lambda times delta.
So I should write here an
approximate equality instead
of an exact
equality, to indicate
that there are other terms,
order of delta squared,
for example, but which are much
smaller compared to the delta.
However, this is
not the only way
that we can get the k-th
arrival in this interval.
There's an alternative scenario.
We might have had k minus 2
arrivals during this interval,
and then two arrivals
during that little interval.
In this case, the
k-th arrival again
occurs within that
little interval.
So we need to also calculate the
probability of this scenario.
The probability of
that scenario is
the probability of k minus
2 arrivals in an interval
of length, y, times the
probability of two arrivals.
But the probability
of two arrivals
is something that's
order of delta squared.
And order of delta
squared is much smaller
than this term, which
is linear in delta.
And so this term can be
ignored as long as we're just
keeping track of
the dominant terms,
those are linear in delta.
And then, they would
be similar expressions.
For example, the scenario
that we have three arrivals up
to time y, and then
three more arrivals
during that little
interval, which is again
an event of probability,
order of delta
squared, that we get
three arrivals there.
And all of those terms
are insignificant,
and we can ignore them.
And we end up with an
approximate equality
between this term and
this expression here.
Delta shows up on both sides,
so we can cancel delta.
And therefore, we have ended
up with a formula for the PDF.
In particular, the PDF is
equal to this probability times
lambda.
What is this probability?
We have a formula for it.
But we just need to substitute.
Put k minus 1 in the place of k,
and put y in the place of tau.
This gives us lambda y
to the power k minus 1, e
to the minus lambda y, divided
by k minus 1 factorial.
And then we have
the extra factor
of lambda, which can be put
together with this lambda
to the k minus 1 here.
And we end up with this final
formula for the PDF of Yk.
The distribution
that we have here
is called an Erlang
distribution.
But actually, it's not
just one distribution.
We have different
distributions depending
on what k we're considering.
The distribution of the
time of the third arrival
is different from
the distribution
of the 10th arrival.
So if we fix a
particular k, then
we say that we have an Erlang
distribution of order k.
For the case where
k is equal to 1,
this term here disappears,
k minus 1 is equal to 0.
And the denominator
term disappears,
and we end up with lambda
times e to the minus lambda y.
But this is the
exponential distribution
that we had already derived
with a different method earlier.
As you increase
k, of course, you
get different distributions.
And these tend to shift
towards the right.
This makes sense.
The time of the
second arrival is
likely to take certain values.
The time of the third
arrival is likely to take
values that are higher.
And the more you increase
k, the more the distribution
will be shifting
towards the right.